[Music]
welcome back to the Georgia podcast
[Music]
really just to be here and you wanted to
be baby beautiful he's at his most
average amount of happiness right now
and peaches at our most average amount
of sadness because she is not in the
burrito sorry
peachy you're gonna have to lay in your
bed you just weren't chosen this time
welcome back anyway guys this episode's
brought to you by me undies the most
wonderful softest and dazzling looking
underwear out there on the market me
Andes is delivered right to your door
three times softer than cotton talked
about it all the time it's the best
underwear I've ever worn and I won't
wear another underwear because of it
right now you guys get 15% off your
first pair free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee when you
go to meet undies comm slash Tony Julian
or hit the link in our description also
guys looking to build a website do it
with Squarespace they make it incredibly
easy Squarespace has designs fonts
images plugins hosting and the best part
is 24/7 customer support that they help
you do whatever you want to do with your
website whatever your websites for your
hobby your business your merch do it
with Squarespace right now guys
Squarespace is giving you 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain
when you go to squarespace.com / - no
Julian or click the link down below you
can also get a free trial so we're gonna
do something today that we've done
before actually it was it's a
choose-your-own-adventure sort of thing
where we go through and play this like
game that's kind of pre-written and you
make choices along the way to you know
determine how you end up who wrote this
one I don't know either
mind you this is I did some research and
I looked into this website and you guys
actually tweeted me a lot of suggestions
because I was looking for websites to do
this on
yeah and one of you tweeted text
adventures dot co dot uk'
and i think it's kind of exactly what
we're looking for because it's a text
adventure it's like a cheese so I
clicked on the horror genre oh my god
because I figured we're gonna do this
that's why Kermit swaddled right now
let's do it right I'm scared I can't
really hear myself that well but I don't
care cuz I look good with this hat
Julian is that better yes
wait it made no difference to you I just
look confused now also how dark is my
facial hair what you think I dyed it you
look nice
can you tell looks like just look a
little bit muddy it does not looks nice
I don't mind it what a compliment what
okay so this one is called texture by
Ralph T Thank You Ralph T wait Ralph
Ralph Ralph RALs which is usually a pH
so he already seems like a little bit
out there the guy or the lady or the
them so this is called texture Ralph
also you have an inventory over here
places and objects encompass don't know
what that's for but let's get started I
type here okay texture by Ralph thison
forest the sound of birds chirping
enters your ears you open your eyes and
slowly stand up trees surround you
it seems you woke up in a forest you try
to remember who you are and what you're
doing here unfortunately you can't
answer these questions your memory is
gone you can go north and then it says
type here so I'm assuming we type go
north or okay okay pass on your command
pass out from fear that's not a command
go and pass out from fear yeah
I don't understand your and I'm sure I
can't see you have to like show me okay
I'm sorry I'm bear with me here okay I'm
not I've not done this okay I like this
this is different than the last we did
because you couldn't type in the last
the last one was multiple-choice only so
this one actually gives you a prompt it
says you can go north okay I feel like
alright go north change colors entrance
you leave the forest behind you
night has fallen the path leads you to
the entrance of what seems to be a house
you can see a gate you can go south or
north oh my god I'm already overwhelmed
well how about this in an attempt for
the story to go north
let's go south but that's where we just
came from true okay so then what happens
if i press north oh okay so you can use
this as an option oh oh it says the
north gate is closed I clicked North and
says the north gate is closed so south
well then don't don't click let's make a
decision together Julien slow down what
do you think well it says the north gate
is closed and there's literally only one
other option so I would think south okay
go so I thought we could continue on
north should i right go north you know
right click north I already tried that
call North the gate is closed oh okay
alright go south sure or go up to the
gate right oh god just retrace our steps
north and then check out the gate you
can see a gate Oh see that okay open try
right open gate you can see a gate let's
try open gate oh you opened the large
gate what what now
what this is hard because it's like I
don't know what words it reads okay just
try enter house hmm
okay so let's what if we try pressing
North because we're past the gate now
house you walk around sorry you walk
towards an old Victorian house you can
see a doormat and a front door you can
go south or north
so we've passed the gate we've seen that
it's an old Victorian house see a
doormat in the front door I would assume
we keep going north mm-hmm okay
go north the front door is locked
you need a key to open it follow the
doormat how do we check the doorman
maybe you just right check the doormat
why don't you just type in doormat doing
that good call
I don't understand your comment or
command hmm
check that doormat what if we click
doorman I can you click it look at take
or move oh that's cool you get prompts
up here okay take I'm kidding look at
look at when you look close enough you
can still see it once had said the word
welcome engraved on it well that is an
opposite all it's a doormat every
doormat system like that what if we move
it our doormat says the Bonjour and it
has a picture of the dachshund you have
a dachshund get it hard or not has
literal quick day get it okay
take press take or something move okay
move yeah you move the door during that
key is visible dude nothing but now
let's go key lose we look at it or take
it I say we just take it take it take it
dude gig wait give me a damn door looks
like a key to the front door of the
house
amazing you take the key front door
let's open the front door yeah yeah get
inside this damn house front doors
locked you need a key to open it what
that oh you can use the key by the way
I'm gonna click 'save periodically
because I think it saves your progress
in case it like closes out alright key
use on which object doormat her front
door doormat front door
use the key to open the front door you
slowly push the heavy door open I'm
scared okay you want to keep walking
forward yeah main hall the heavy front
door closes behind you that was a bad
door sound hold on the heavy front door
closes behind you how's that you try to
open it but it's locked it seems like
you're trapped inside you find yourself
in the main hall of the Victorian house
although it's quite dark some candles in
the ceiling chandelier dimly lit the
main hall you can see a staircase a
front door and a chandelier
you can go west up or south I'm
overwhelmed by choices now let's go up
up up I like any time that they give me
the option to go up let's go up by the
way if you're watching this on YouTube
the reason we've created so much space
between us is a because we're friends
and be because we want you guys to be
able to see play the prompts behind us
anyway I said we go west okay we can go
west
let's go west west kitchen you're in the
rather small kitchen of the house the
kitchen is a complete mess all cabinets
but one are destroyed sounds like maybe
my kitchen it's very seasoned in that Oh
see a cabinet you can go east ok so we
can investigate in the cabinet I want to
look at the cabin look in the cabinet
look at old cabinet looks like it almost
falls apart okay let's open it yeah I'm
gonna open it you gently opened the
cabinet doors the cabinet contains a
blister strip what is that is that like
a a band-aid for when you get a blister
I don't know what the blister strip
maybe a band-aid that sounds nasty why
would that be in there is it some sort
of thing that I don't know about cuz
that's not really possible I don't know
I don't know okay
do we have any options blister strip
look at take let's look at it yeah an
empty blister strip that seems to have
contained medication to treat chronic
aggressive behavior what the hell kind
of oh I see Oh bless your strip like you
know when you have pills and you push
them through the plastic to the other
side so it's met it's like meds yeah God
got it okay creepy mmm take it take it
it's ours now eat it put in your body
okay now we have the blister strip we
have the cabinet should we close it or
no yeah no I like to leave it open oh
I'm feeling very anxious you gently
close the cabinet doors all right let's
go back east
okay because it says you can go east
that's the only door okay so we go east
where the front hall now with the dimly
lit chandelier you can go west upper
south so we already went west want to go
up let's go up okay first floor you're
on the first floor of the old house you
can see a painting you can go east down
or west let's look at the painting look
at the painting intrigued by the
painting you walk towards it the bloody
eyes of a woman are painted on it and
they seem to stare at you suspiciously
you closely look into her bloody eyes
nothing happens we're an art thief or an
art thief okay not only are we
trespassing we're breaking and entering
but but listen you know I didn't break
anything and enter because the key was
there
I'm pretty sure that's sound
breaking-and-entering in court
it's too heavy we can't take the
painting but sir there was a key there I
did it it was fine but sir come in all
right your honor
the painting is too heavy okay we can't
take it then we can go east down or west
do you want to go east upstairs master
bedroom everything just turned red
master bedroom you find yourself in what
seems to be the master bedroom of the
house you shiver as you look around the
room the Baroque wallpaper design on the
walls is covered in blood stains a blood
trail leads to the bathroom on the east
you can see a bed a closet and a desk
you can go west or east can we touch the
blood on the wall is that an option just
look like you're so loud in my
headphones when you do that it's
actually physically hurting you lower
your headset yes please is it any better
yeah it's better make sure you turn this
to full volume and pop those air pods in
those ears let's let's look at the stuff
like the bed or the process yeah so
let's look at the bed first
it's a king-sized bed the sheets are
stained with blood
I've blood everywhere cause it look at
the closet yeah
closet is filled with some men's
clothing and a lot of women's clothing
and shoes women be like almost
everything contains bloodstains the door
of the closet lay broken on the floor
what happened here should be open so
everything is covered in blood seems
like most will the wall the bed and some
of the closet you want to open the
closet yeah
even though me karthik Cardian huh you
can't open it okay
let's close it you can't close it oh
okay
desk look at the desk yeah it's just an
ordinary desk okay and markup can we
take the bed yeah take the bed take the
bed
you don't want to touch that oh not too
heavy it's just you don't want to touch
that who are they to presume okay so we
can go west or east we already went east
so we can either go further east or go
back to the keep going all the way east
cuz east as we can pather bathroom you
follow the blood trail and enter the
bathroom you can see a curtain and a
toilet you can go west all right let's
open the curtain look at look at the
curtain the curtain hides the bath and
is covered with blood okay open the
curtain
he opened the curtain the bath is
visible oh I wasn't expecting that bath
look at the huge bath is filled with a
large amount of blood it looks like
someone or something is slaughtered here
know it can we can we drop one real
quick look at the toilet there's a
kitchen knife laying on the toilet seat
oh okay we're not dropping one let's
look at the kitchen knife I'm gonna just
go ahead and take take a shot in the
dark gasp here there might be blood on
the kitchen knife a bloody kitchen knife
I think you should take it for
protection
you take the kitchen knife okay that's
the first thing we've been allowed to
actually take oh no we took the meds so
in our inventory we have the blister
strip and the kitchen knife and the key
to the house but we use oh you already
used it okay so now I think we can just
go west
right yeah go west
we're in the bedroom again let's go West
again you're on the first floor all
right let's go West
okay here we go study you're in the
study of the house wait is this the
house that clue was based on it feels
like it might be the library next
I've never played clue I just can't play
clue oh my god
you're in the study of the house someone
seems to have had a fight with a laptop
in a lot of books you can see a laptop
and a bookshelf you can go east
oh there's laptop I didn't know the time
period of this me neither
let's open the laptop okay a modern
looking laptop doesn't seem to work
anymore the screen is completely
shattered who would have done this who
could have done this okay you want to
take it yeah I mean while we're thieving
we could get some good coin for that you
don't need the parts but you'll know
that you don't know my situation don't
look at the bookshelf okay okay let's
look at the bookshelf there are still
some books left on the shelf one
particular book catches your eye and
Frank the Diary of a young girl should
we look at the book is that the actual
title of that I don't know or is this
like I thought it was called just the
Diary of Anne Frank no it seems to be
the Diary of a young girl by Anne Frank
Wow I did not know that yeah so it's
legit okay the book I've read it I just
didn't know that was the title yeah
ready we're legally in the book oh it
just gave us the title again do we take
the book or do we leave it take it take
the book wait I wonder why that book's
there take book you want to take the
book off the shelf but the book seems to
work as a lever you remove your hand
from the book and watch how the
bookshelf makes way for a secret room to
the north we why you
oh so we touch the book and it opened
the swivel door and that takes us to
that North Carolina
secret room you found what seems to be a
secret room the room is dimly lit by the
light coming from the study some empty
boxes fill the room you can see a ladder
and boxes you can go south or up I feel
like we got to go up I want to go up
wait
go up good okay slow down slow down okay
well what do you want to do at this
point no I mean yeah we agree you want
to go up I like just I'm not ready to go
up yeah I got to think all the time you
want why don't you want you want to take
the reigns yeah okay we're going up
you're gonna block me off completely
that's what it's like so yeah open to
the both of us okay you ready addict
you're in the attic a lot of small
candles lit the room past tense you can
see a mirror and candles you can go down
can we look at the mirror and the
candles yeah which one you want to look
at first come here look at oh we gonna
see me okay
a large floor standing mirror with a
baroque style frame
strangely enough you can't see the image
of yourself in it so it's it's a mirror
but you can't see yourself yeah what the
hell wait so I don't know how to use
these controls what do you need to know
that you don't know want to take the
mirror you can try it's too heavy
yeah figures are candles I'm pretty
strong I don't know let's look at the
candles okay
small candles lit the Attucks want to
take some candles mm-hmm they're too hot
wait a sec can we blow them out Oh what
if we use the kitchen knife on the
candle I don't know use on which object
blister strip mirror our candles mirror
you want to use the knife on the mirror
yeah let's let's smash it
okay let's try we click mirror you hope
we what ok just took me to totally
different screen you hold the bloody
kitchen knife in front of the mirror you
wonder why the image of the knife in the
mirror is not covered in blood
suddenly the mirror starts to glow and a
powerful energy grabs you and pulls you
towards the mirror you can't resist it
before you know it you're sucked into
the mirror oh [ __ ] it says continue
addict you find yourself on the floor in
front of the mirror you
slowly stand up and look at the kitchen
knife the knife is clean as expected the
image of the knife in the mirror shows
an example covered in blood could you be
on the other side of the mirror you're
in the Attic a lot of small candles lit
the room you can see a mirror and
candles you can go down okay we just hop
dimensions so now maybe we can go down
and figure out what happened maybe we
need to go to the bedroom yeah yeah yeah
let's go to the bedroom so you go down
and then East I think you can also do
this if you want to have to go down okay
you're in the secret room the room is
dimly lit by the light coming from the
study some boxes packed with books fill
the room you can see a ladder in boxes
let's look at the boxes mm-hmm they
weren't there before they're filled with
books they're filled with books all
right I'm gonna take a book see if we
can take one try yeah it says you don't
need those okay so let's go what about
my quest for learning not the time we're
trying to survive in the other dimension
it's never too late to learn I thought
you said it wasn't the time for reading
that was yesterday
Oh today is the time for reading yeah
okay okay so we keep going down I think
so yeah yourself because we want to get
to the bedroom mm-hmm
study okay so now we can go east again
okay first for your various floor what
yeah I want to see if the painting has
bloody eyes click on the painting and
see if we can look at it again okay
painting yeah look at intrigued by the
painting you walk towards it the
beautiful eyes of a woman are painted on
it and they seemed to stare at you
suspiciously you closely look into her
beautiful eyes nothing happens
there's no blood so far no blue
everything's clean and happy okay let's
go to the bedroom
whoops do I go to the right or left yeah
East okay master bedroom you find
yourself in what seems to be the master
bedroom of the house the room is
decorated with wallpaper umber
design you can see a bed a closet in a
desk we keep going in or you want to
look at the desk or the bed bed let's
look at the bed it's a king-sized bed
the sheets look clean this is a triple
mm-hmm
let's look at the closet mm-hmm it's a
huge closet with big doors well you
don't say there has to be more should we
go
let's look at the desk just to make sure
we're covering all our bases oh there's
a note lying on the desk okay look at
the note let's look at the note the note
reads I'm sorry but I just can't take it
any longer
take it yep so no you take the note all
right finally we got an item y'all give
me that damn note
give me that damn so go east we go to
the bathroom now okay let's go to the
scene of the crime you enter the
bathroom you can see a curtain and a
toilet you can go west as we can look at
the car yeah there's probably no blood
but you'll get it
okay the curtain hides the bath mm-hmm
want to try opening it again hmm
you open the curtain the bath is visible
you have to look at the bath do I have
an option to bathe it's a huge bath take
a bath take take bath you can't take it
toilet oh this is where you found the
knife mmm okay look at the toilet
it's just an ordinary toilet with a
wooden toilet seat Wow what year is it
go there was a laptop so true we also
could just be in the upside down take
the toilet okay so I think we have to go
downstairs yeah I guess so
so I'll head back to the first floor and
then go down go down yeah so main hall
mm-hmm we didn't oh this is where we
enter
mm-hmm so if we go south that means
we're leaving the house right yeah and
if we go west going into the kitchen so
I guess we should go to the kitchen
yeah let's check it out we haven't seen
it since we've switched sides yeah okay
okay you're in a rather small kitchen of
the house the kitchen looks clean you
can see a cabinet you can go east
we should definitely check the cabinet
okay look the old cabinet looks like new
open let's open the cabinet you gently
open the cabinet doors the cabinet
contains a power supply take the power
supply should we Jam our knife into it
okay use kitchen knife oh no cabinet or
powers of power supply you can't use it
that way [ __ ] yeah all right it was a
good idea
what if we use the can you turn on the
power supply open it gives you a sorry
take is the only option
well we haven't looked at it yet okay
then let's look at the power supply a
power supply that seems to be designed
for a laptop takes the laptop no but we
can go to the study it said it wouldn't
let us take the laptop right yeah but
what if we go to the study where the
laptop is and use the power supply on
the laptop oh we took the power supplies
yeah we have the power supply so if we
go back to the Eastman upstairs and then
to the west there this is where the
study is to the right and then to the
west I think study okay you can see a
laptop yes okay so use power supply and
see if it gives us an option for laptop
that's all right we're gonna use the
power supply on the laptop you connect
the power supply to the laptop oh my god
dude where do the files are whew
oh no laptop look at turn on okay you
turn on the laptop after the laptop
started up an article on the website of
what seems to be the local police
department is displayed on the screen
okay look at the screen okay the article
is titled woman found dead in forest you
read the article the lifeless body of a
still ident on identified young woman
was found in the forest last night by a
runner
the woman has long blonde hair and was
dressed in a short red dress black
pantyhose and red high-heeled shoes we
believe she was murdered and possibly
raped she has multiple head injuries and
her eyes are missing medical personnel
have determined that the cause of death
is exsanguination is that a fancy way of
saying strangled oh due to a cut-throat
injury Oh
if you have any information that can
help us solving this murder we highly
encourage you to contact your local
police department immediately you feel
strange and dizzy suddenly a picture of
the bloody eyes of a woman appear in
your head
the image frightens you you've seen
those bloody eyes somewhere yeah this is
super creepy
what are you doing check out squares
first guys this episode is brought to
you by Squarespace and right now you can
build your own website using Squarespace
look at all these beautiful options it
gives you four templates and features to
make your website look beautiful on
desktop mobile tablets they have 24/7
personal support it's amazing
click on templates let's see what they
got here look at all the customization
you can do they have different
categories health and fitness all you
want to see here and then they give you
options for what it might look like
given previous websites or even mock-up
websites that have been made with it
and are giving you 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain you can
try it for free but I guarantee you're
gonna like it and then you can check it
out with our discount code and start
building you can build a whole website
and you don't need to be a coder or a
professional in this space at all you
can be anyone who wants to just build a
website for something you want to build
it for so go to Squarespace calm Jenna
Julian like that BAM look at that 10%
discount right there it's all you got to
do Oh check it out you will be
incredibly surprised at how easy the
process is and check it out they have
online stores case capabilities for you
to build in your web sites you can do a
blog you can do a lookbook whatever you
want check it out and then when you're
done with that go to me and use calm
slash Jenna Julian and check out their
awesome collection of underwear and bra
flats and onesies oh look at that we
know these people that's us that's
really cute and you get 50% off your
first order and free shipping check it
out though you can shop all the
underwear you want they have an awesome
thing where you can get his in a hers or
his in his or hers and hers a dual pair
so that you can match with your
significant other or best friend like us
a couple of friends a couple of friends
you click on it you see all the options
they have mystery packs you can sign up
for a subscription this is what I'll
just talking about matching undies is
very cool and the membership is where it
comes regularly and you don't have to go
shopping for underwear because it just
comes to your house so click on the link
below and check it out and they also if
you're into things more than underwear
they have modal thong packs they have
socks they have bikini packs bra let's
onesies
it is pretty limitless so check it out
go to Squarespace sorry I'm me and these
are compilation of Julian and then go to
squares major comes in generally or
click both links in the description
below so you don't have to remember any
URL it's there for you and enjoy all of
what they have to offer thank you to our
sponsors and back to the story now okay
you can keep going from here I'm scared
this article I love you you know my
friend I love you okay is that joke over
so we should be done I'm just scared of
the story oh okay so you can't friends
on me when you're scared
Wow classic okay let's just analyze this
for a second woman found dead in forest
we started in the forest mm-hmm so where
the woman is very possible well they
didn't say they're hearing out our
murder they didn't maybe they didn't
identify our gender no so we could be
the woman we also could be the murderer
we could because we started in the
forest the lifeless body was still
identified unidentified young young
woman was found in the forest last night
by a runner we could be the runner the
woman has long blonde hair was dressed
in a short dress see we would know all
this if we looked in the mirror and it
was a normal [ __ ] Mirko we could go
back to the mirror cuz it's not weird
anymore oh we already did there's just
no blood that's why we popped out yeah
hmm okay so you've seen these body eyes
somewhere let's go back to the painting
okay do we have to go through the mirror
again I don't know I don't know either I
don't know what to do scream okay can we
take that blister pack medication or
what I
only gives you the option to drop it or
look at it eat it no option to eat it no
there's no option eat it okay okay good
talk what if we go further into the
study to the secret room okay all right
let's go north secret room you're in the
secret room the room is dimly lit by the
light coming from the study some boxes
packed with books fill the room you can
see a ladder in boxes you can go up or
south so we went up last time and that's
where you found the mirror I think let's
try it again so you're trying to go back
to the mirror now I guess go up my safe
oh it's freezing on me oh good
SpaghettiOs nothing's working oh no oh
no Julien what do we do okay and we're
back
sorry for the inconvenience Oh our
internet and dropped out and we lost our
place so we are safe now I saved the
progress and we are back where the
mirror is but we're on like the good
side where there's no blood still right
so we have the knife we learned about
the article you've seen these bloody
eyes somewhere okay we go back to the
attic where the mirror is let's look at
the mirror a large floor-standing mirror
with a baroque style frame strangely
enough you can't see image of yourself
and it candles let's look at the candles
small candles light the Attic
all right let's use the knife on the
mirror again you hold a clean kitchen
knife in front of the mirror suddenly
the mirror starts to glow and a powerful
energy grabs you and pulls you towards
the mirror you're sucked in the mirror
so just like the other time whoa okay so
I think we're in the dark side of things
now but we should we should go back to
the light side and then maybe go outside
yeah yeah maybe we can go to the back to
the forest
yeah okay let's let's all right we
sucked herself back in the mirror we're
on the light side
let's go down let's go south let's go
outside we open up the boxes okay let's
go south let's go to the top of the
stairs let's go to the bottom of the
stairs and let's go out the front door
you're unable to open the heavy front
door front door can we use the knife on
the candles or the blister pack I don't
know let's look at the chandelier no
just no it says all the candles burn
bright so it's really light out
nothing really threatening let's go
outside come on let us open the [ __ ]
come on let's open the [ __ ] door come
in the door
damn okay hmm what do we do I'm gonna go
to the kitchen again okay
cabinet we've been here mm-hmm it's
already open closed take can't take it
okay we do we go upstairs it's our only
option
all right upstairs again we do we get
the note yet I retraced the steps maybe
I missed the note okay no here we go
yeah okay what does the note say I'm
sorry but I just can't take any longer
okay so we have the note now I retrace
that step um can we go outside now or
can we go through the mirror now I don't
know well we already know we can go
through the mirror all right let's go
downstairs and go up west or south main
hall we can go up oh that was where we
were hmm painting
isn't there you know when you get to the
secret room you can either go up or
south or something like have you tried
going south from there let's check I
think South just retrace the steps for
in the study north or east
let's go north you can go up herself
what happens if you go oh if you go east
from the study then you just go back to
the main hall yeah so hmm kind of stuck
here latter take I wonder if we can use
the okay use the ladder climb you're in
the Attic oh okay
okay use the candles on the mirror or
the blister pack on the mirror candles
are too hot blister strip all gives us
an option to do with the blister chef is
take a look at it or drop it hmm you're
in the Attic
mirror let's look at the mirror
strangely enough you can't see yourself
what if we used it what if we go back to
the dark side now that we found the note
and like cuz the note was not on the
dark side it was my light side right
what if we go back to the dark side
now that we read what happened to the
girl and we got that note maybe if we go
back to the dark side we'll have more
options that's the move
alright we're using the knife on the
mirror we're back to the dark side let's
go down oh wait no yeah let's go down go
south or up
let's go south no we're in the study now
in the study top oh let's look at the
laptop shattered screen okay oh oh this
isn't looking too good for us
alright we're at the top of the let's
see if we can go out the door again yeah
okay let's go down out the door unable
to open the heavy front door so that's
normal for both sides so we stuck in
this house on both sides beach
chandeliers pretty doors the painting we
haven't looked at the painting again
it's in like them oh my god you're right
we looked at the painting yeah intrigued
by the painting you walk towards it the
bloody eyes of a woman are painted on it
and they seem to stare at you
suspiciously
you closely look into her bloody eyes
you remember these eyes these eyes
belonged to your wife she couldn't take
it any longer and wanted to leave you
but you couldn't let that happen
anger fills your body as a poison
suddenly everything begins to shake the
painting falls off the wall and hits
your head everything turns black shivers
dude okay so it gives us as a place an
object a small hole so we should look at
it yeah continue master-bedroom you find
yourself and what seems to be the master
bedroom of the house your wife is busy
packing her clothes you can see your
wife bed a closet and a desk you can use
the kitchen knife it gives you the
option to use the kitchen knife you
still have it and the blister strip can
we eat that medication finally to lower
our aggressiveness oh it's his look at
her drop oh ok so let's see why look at
wife okay yeah look at wife she wears a
sexy short red dress dress black
pantyhose and red high heels this isn't
sorry this is how you like to see her
she's always dressed like she's going to
a party but she isn't going to a party
this time she seems to pack her things
and wants to leave she leave in our ass
she's dressed in the sexiest lingerie so
we know what we're missing out on when
she's leaving us she's not wearing
lingerie Gelinas a dress sexy though
forget
all right let's speak to her okay you
try to speak to her but she ignores you
no damn fields wife please come back
wife bed look at lay lay the king-sized
bed is there an option to seduce her in
the bed the sheets are clean make it
make a funny joke so she doesn't want to
go closet your closet is filled with
some men's clothing and a lot of women's
clothing and shoes your wife is busy
packing her clothes okay we know that
desk let's look at the desk
she's known
desk all right let's look at the note
okay the note reads I'm sorry but I just
can't take any longer
so that's doesn't wait so is there only
option right now to use the knife on our
wife honestly yes we've tried everything
else
thanks a lot use knife on our way use it
on the closet house he's on a closet you
can't use it that way ah you saw the bed
get your anger out some other way you
can't use it that way use on the blister
strip you can't use it that way use it
on the desk on the note you can't use it
that way please oh you don't have any
more options we have to use them now you
gotta do it on your wife use the knife
on the wife oh god this is gnarly okay
this might be triggering actually so
trigger warning I think yeah definitely
trigger warning you walk towards her
should I read this I don't know I don't
know what it's okay grab her and throw
her against the closet she screams but
no one will hear you
hmm yeah I'm not gonna read this you
pretty much just murder her that's what
I'll say let's continue
that's very graphic it's very graphic
I didn't I only read one part of it it
does like a pair yeah I think it was
probably arty we already know the way
that she dies in her eyes and her throat
yes so it's that and the fact that
there's blood everywhere a really really
unnecessarily gratuitous sorry
description of yeah okay anyway all
make-believe guys why are there so many
birds outside they're just like circling
our house okay wait what
black crows circling our house
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not circling our house he's just
there's one in that tree and he's just
having a good time mining in his own
business
if you see like a flock of them yeah
it's a little ominous but like you find
yourself in what seems to be the master
bedroom of the house the Baroque
wallpaper design on the walls is covered
in blood stains a blood trail leads to
the bathroom on the east you can see a
bed a closet a desk and an emblem you
can go west or east
what's an emblem let's look at it wait I
don't see if we can take her meds no I
still can't take her meds look at the
emblem really [ __ ] up a small stone
emblem with a tree engraved on it I want
it okay you take the epilim should we
leave the room now should we look at the
desk
just not in our desk yeah I thought
maybe this was like a chance for us to
go back and make it right but we didn't
well we didn't have the chance to didn't
give us the option - all right let's go
into the bathroom bathroom seems locked
from the other side okay let's go back
to the first floor
wait so someone's locked in the bathroom
well the it's locked from the inside so
we don't know ah so this is where the
painting used to be and the first floor
of this the first landing yeah now
there's a small hole Oh
cuz it fell off and hit us in the head
maybe let's look at the hole you looked
through the small hole and see the
completely overgrown garden behind the
house
unfortunately the small hole is just big
enough for a mouse to get through take
why is that unfortunate I'd love for a
mouse to come into my house you can't
take it okay
you want to go downstairs yeah I guess
though go downstairs oh you can't go
downstairs because the staircase
collapsed um was ever earthquake or
something that I missed
hello all right let's go west into the
study what the weight of the study is
blocked by a big pile of rubble what is
going on we can't all right we got to go
back to the bedroom you find yourself
and what seems to be the master version
of the house that baroque old wallpaper
design on the walls is covered in blood
stains blood trail leads to the bathroom
on the east you can see a bed of closet
desk you can go west or east well we use
the knife or something on the bathroom
door so we don't have a knife anymore we
have a note the meds and an emblem let's
try to go to the bathroom it's locked
from the other side so we can't go
anywhere upstairs what if we use the
emblem yeah on which object we can use
them on the blister strips so we can
open up the blister shirt oh you can't
use it okay all right let's use it on
the note the try anything
all right let's use it on the note nope
it's use it on the bed can't use it that
way let's use it on the no it's not
using anything what's the last one desk
can't use it that way we can't use the
wait so we can't go anywhere upstairs
except for the locked bathroom door mmm
in the bedroom and the bedroom has a bed
a closet in a desk as we know what the
closet
look at the closet closet is filled with
men's clothing you know yeah
the door is laid broken on the floor oh
never mind the women's clothing and
shoes almost everything contains blood
the doors lay broken on the floor okay
well you try and stuff
let's open can't open it let's take it
you don't want to touch that desk just
an ordinary desk take a look at the
king-size bed the sheets are stained
with blood take don't want to touch that
I don't understand when you go to the
hallway it's just a hole and that's it
mm-hmm
really yeah you can't go up we haven't
looked at the note yet since I don't
know I'm sorry but as you can't take any
longer hmm you want to go back to the
main landing I don't know I'm a little
confused all right so we're on the
landing above the stairs you're on the
first floor which means the second go
east down or west so we go down it's
blocked
staircase collapse we go west rubble on
the way can't get to the study or
downstairs we can only get to the
bathroom if we use the emblem on the
small hole oh we place the emblem firmly
in the hole and hear it click the tree
on the emblem suddenly lights up it
hurts your eyes a high-pitched sound
enters your ears and you slowly lose
consciousness holy crap dude what forest
the sound of police sirens enters your
ears you open your eyes and slowly stand
up trees surround you it seems you woke
up in a forest a policeman shouts police
put your hands up you put your hands in
the air you're arrested for the murder
of your wife continue that's it oh my
god so basically we just what I don't
get where were we when we start it
that's the weird part in the forest but
if there was already blood everywhere we
killed our wife in our house and then we
dragged her body into the forest so we
must have passed out or fallen asleep or
something in the forest somebody found
her body and then we had this dream
where we went back and you know I guess
revealed to ourselves what we had done
and then we woke up and we were getting
arrested that's so gnarly I guess the
worst part though is that like you could
go over to the good side or the previous
side where nothing had happened yet and
you couldn't do anything yeah like we
tried everything yeah damn that's dark
do you know it was dark I'm scary
that's scary why didn't he just take his
medicine I know I well the thing is I
wonder if there was a different outcome
no no there has to be I feel so
unsatisfied I feel sad I feel sad want a
hug yeah
if you're listening on itunes we're
hugging I mean that's like the thing
about these choose your own adventures
is like you don't know what you're gonna
get mm you could get something like last
when we did where that guy was part of
like that gang and he had to go kill a
bunch of people and that [ __ ] was gnarly
yeah but it's like what how do you
expect me there's nothing it's a story
there's no way to expect what's gonna
happen I was really fun though it was
fun I like the format of that it's like
a game almost yeah honestly I feel like
what what school right is anyone can go
on this website I think actually I'm
sure there are websites like it but
anyone can go on a
choose-your-own-adventure website and
write your your fiction but you can
create your own story so in theory like
the one of you guys could make a really
cool one and we could read it on the
podcast the only problem is is like we
can't vet it you know I mean we'd have
to have some way it first we would have
to have someone play it first to make
sure it's all good and and like good
enough to play on the podcast and that's
kind of like the hard part about playing
these we don't have a producer we don't
have anyone yeah this is just running
this podcast so like I don't know maybe
we could think of a way to do this to
where we have it pre-screened we have it
ready or even like personalized to like
the podcast that was really I like that
that was fun that was fun it was also
different than the first time that we
did it because the first one was very
much a story yes and this one was more
of like a almost a physical game that
you're choosing your physical location
it felt like a like a murder mystery
game yeah which was cool and there
wasn't nearly as much swearing as the
last one you remember how much swearing
there was it was a lot it was really
gnarly but anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed listening newest player
choose-your-own-adventure is fine feel
free to tweet at us if you have ideas on
how we can do this better given it's
just Jenna and myself running the
podcast you know you guys like it though
you guys like it fine well it's like I
was you know I was going through our old
podcast and this one you guys really
loved so I was like let's just do
another one
part two you so know screaming okay
mommy's gonna give you a hug now now
Kermit's crying and that means it's time
in the podcast so I hope you guys have a
wonderful week have a wonderful rest of
your car ride have a wonderful nap or
night's sleep and we'll see you guys on
the next one
have a good one
[Music]